there's a disappointing story that came
out that i think we have to start off
with and i hope it doesn't break your
heart
okay i hope you guys can emotionally
handle this one here especially folks
out there that are
um struggling with a lot of challenges
that they're going through
stats came out yesterday okay
that a name that was named
in 1965 33 000
kids were named karen last year only 325
heartbreaking are you disappointed by
that godmother can you please pull that
up
my godmother's name karen variely
i swear karen variely i mean that's his
news
go type and go actually uh go to go type
in
just go on google and type in karen name
popularity
name popular look at the stats here man
it's it's uh you haven't seen it right
there just go down to come up
just type in popularity not the graph
just any article
any article kai you go to any article
there you go look at this go to
uh tmz go for it name carrot popularity
plummets from 32 000 to 325.
uh number 668.31 uh
325 carrots versus 33 000. by the way
go to the other website i gave you go to
the other website i gave you so i looked
up our names
okay i looked up our names go to
it's crazy if you go to jennifer go all
the way down on popularity go all the
way down on popularity
jennifer was number one for an entire
decade go all the way down
jennifer always tells me about this look
at this from 1970
baby if you're watching this till 1984
jennifer was the number one name in
america
what happened i have no idea that's like
millions right i mean
every year that's like every jennifer
jennifer jennifer jennifer go to gerard
look what gerard looks like i studied
all year now
i've been investigating
let's look up gerard gold popularity if
you go down look at that look at that
that if that was a stock that's not a
good stock but by the way
all of our stocks look like that go down
this is what it looks like
gerard's not even ranked not in the last
few years but gerard's peak
was uh keep going down keep going down
keep going down
okay you got to go up there was a 179
you racked one keep going up there was
ranking uh 177 at the time
when hey 54. my father 1958 look at that
was born in 58. yeah jerome
you're going to die it was 191. now type
in thomas
thomas here we go a very rare name yeah
don't know
it's not i stand out in my family it's
the rarest name in the world are you
doubting thomas
go down go look at look at this look at
the stock at the top by the way go back
up there
will you come back to the trend look
from eighteen eighty
okay obviously time is that roosevelt
where everybody's naming their kids uh
well that's teddy then it goes 1950 or
pekin
then go all the way down look at let's
look at the ranking look at this but
you've been in the top 50 for quite some
time
top ten extremely competitive name for a
long time now go to patrick go to
patrick go to patrick let's check this
out
kai you may want to test yourself out as
well in america although it's probably
uh higher ranking in different places
look at patrick we peaked
i wonder what happened in the 70s and
60s we peaked
major drop off we got some work to do
right now it's ranked 205 gold lower
color the highest we got to was in the
30s
30 30 and then boom dropped off now is
this percentage based or is this just
right so who which name was given the
most during that year
we're just not having kids anymore so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]